dude there's a um i don't even know if i
want to share because i don't want to
like make people do it more but the
first show in san diego oof
i like to pause i heard about this i
like to [ __ ] pulse
okay i take my pause but when you're in
a [ __ ] theater and there's 2 000
people there and these people are
[ __ ] drunk you know what i mean
who knows what's going on
so i'm in this pause and then somebody
starts to yell another person starts to
yell something and then a few people say
so i just get [ __ ] upset i just go
man i'm not gonna [ __ ] go and i'm
just staring at them yeah i'm like
eventually they're gonna get
uncomfortable and they're gonna realize
they should probably stop talking yeah
and the old hitler
what is that hitler used to do
really good
just yelled at him no he would pause
really
is it is it worse that it came naturally
for you
that's true yeah you've got to be like i
just thought that was the natural thing
to do great public speakers guys listen
we're going to have some things to come
move over about four feet
[Laughter]
so these people are like yelling stuff
i'm not saying anything and then
eventually it gets like
very
i mean like it's obvious
i'm not talking
they're yelling and what are you talking
about like a couple minutes so long that
i took my phone out after 30 seconds
when i got awkward filmed for probably a
minute and then put my phone away and
then took it back out and filmed again
like there was two it was like it could
have been five minutes no
it wasn't five minutes yeah it was so
long i walked from the cameras to
backstage to check is everything okay
yeah
like i thought something went wrong like
i don't think a lot of like at least in
the city like
if something's annoying i'm usually
behaved pretty well in the clubs in the
city you know because like people are
coming out for everybody else you know
but like what are you what
you saw
i behaved myself nobody's having a
stroke you're not an [ __ ] but you're
not like hey you know i'm usually in him
so i just kicked the whole roll out i'll
kick the whole row out
in the if i'm on the road the whole row
can go yeah yeah like i have a thing
that i do like if people keep my
standards no no you're eliminating
sections the whole thing goes wow no and
i have a rule where if if somebody keeps
talking
not only do they have to go the people
around them that enabled that i'll be
honest also very nazi like
they'd be like they were partisans we're
killing the whole town technically it's
north korea cleansing
multiple generations
okay everybody gets punished you allowed
this to happen
you're talking the whole show you go too
yeah and the person next to you and they
control the banks and it's like
that is true
that is true when do we stop come on we
need to protect
we need to protect
the [ __ ] dictator so
i'm sitting there i'm just standing
outside people are starting to yell
stuff and i think it's about to like die
down right
and then all of a sudden it dies down
and then all of a sudden this one kind
of back goes uh
be silent if you're gay
son
it [ __ ] broke me dude
it [ __ ] broke me there's nothing i
could do and i laughed and i literally
just had to go [ __ ] it was good yeah you
gave it up
that's a true comic
you were so pissed but a good joke
you're like i was good
and there's nothing i could do if i stay
silent i'm gay
yeah you're not yet okay guys
i don't want you to know
no but and if i don't acknowledge it a
lot at all there's nothing there's no
coming back from it no so that was it
but [ __ ] man yeah sometimes they get you
now anybody listening to this we are
absolutely infuriated when you guys do
this [ __ ] so shut the [ __ ] up yeah
really isn't working on that either no
no no no they should know you they
should know
yeah everybody's never been to a comedy
show and then they sometimes that
they're [ __ ] helping yeah some people
really think they're helping you this
guy this guy got me sat or friday night
okay phoenix i get done there's a guy
out at the bar and i'm walking by him
and he goes that was the worst [ __ ]
show i've ever seen in my life
and i thought i was so serious i i
thought he was joking so i was like oh
thanks for coming out man he was like no
that was a piece of [ __ ] show
me and my wife walked out and we've been
out here the whole time waiting why dude
i've no id i couldn't figure out why it
could have been the navy seal stuff to
be honest i think it was i think it was
he looked like tell them that you were
you went to west point
what what would that mean
in high school but you played for
[ __ ] air force army no i quit right
away oh i thought you were like no i
thought you were a jar hit no
no i thought he was anyway i get out
there this guy hits me with yeah this
looks like i served yeah
[Laughter]
this guy hit me with that was the worst
[ __ ] show i've ever seen he looked
like and i i like
i usually don't get mad but i was like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] like right to his
face in front of his wife and people had
to like separate us after the show wow
did he do anything no he did well either
did i
but no i called him a [ __ ] and that was
the end of it but then he has to do
something to you to prove he's not a
[ __ ] i know i was surprised i didn't
get punched he's a [ __ ] yeah it turns
out he's a [ __ ] yeah you heard you were
right you was a big 55 year old man who
would have and it sucked too because it
was right in front of the line
white but he was from phoenix so like
dark leathery yeah yeah
there was a the line for the next show
was right there watching oh [ __ ] this
guy's like that was the worst piece of
[ __ ] i've ever seen and then you get a
fight with him
and everyone was like holy [ __ ] dude
it's gonna be a wild show and the second
show was great second year is gonna be
so fire yeah it was fun
because you called him a [ __ ] no it
doesn't matter he won he won the war why
do you win the war why well maybe he's
still dwelling on him in front of his
wife he might still be dwelling on it i
see why he didn't serve in war i don't
think you know how to win wars but yeah
well i would have done well in the
united states then
shout out
[Laughter]
taliban home
but uh
no he won the war because i'm still
thinking about it because you know what
[ __ ] me
i hope he's thinking about but what
bothered me was i don't know what he was
mad at if i knew which one because it's
not like he the show was bad
it was a good show the crowd liked it
but there was one thing i said that must
have yeah because here's the thing
people that are going to your shows
still
don't know you yeah so you have a
certain amount of people they're just
going there to laugh yeah right with no
expectation what they're about to hear
yeah you know and um
then you start rooting for the taliban
people
no i understand and if people don't like
the show i tell them like
leave it's not a i won't be offended if
you don't like the show and leave yeah
it is but if you get offended and then
wait outside of the bar
and then call it like be walk up and be
like a worst [ __ ] show what a loser
that is though that on a friday or
saturday night yeah they don't have
better things to do than sit there and
wait for you to stop it they paid the
whole night for the babysitter they're
not gonna let her off early go eat
dinner somewhere they got some drinks
waiting for him no you can't get food
i'm going to the club for two hours yep
whether we watch him or not i'm going to
be there for two hours he must have
waited a half hour at least half hour
just sat there just like tell them i'm
going to tell him he can still kind of
hear the jokes
every time a waitress opens the door you
just hear it coming so the taliban
[ __ ]
yeah there's a guy that doesn't know
twitter exists you know man like you
just go home and talk
that would have hurt more
like a public tweet yeah but if it was
contained
he's an older guy he's 55 years old
i hope it worked i hope he's because i
and it wasn't like a
sheepish you're a [ __ ] like i wasn't
like yeah well you're a [ __ ] yeah you
wanted i was literally like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it was nice
but he actually
and he could he could have socked me i
would have it would have been funny
going on stage after he got punched in
the mouth
last show was all right
so if you get offended please leave
don't exist
don't physically assault me please
but weirdly isn't it kind it's almost
what you want them to do
like you don't want him to have that
interaction during the show
and i'm sure that's happened to you
before yeah last time i was there that
room really yeah same guy
probably he's like i gave you a second
shoe there's a guy who yelled the n-word
last time i was there white or black
white he was related to shane obviously
he wasn't one of my favorites
no what happened there was a comedian
before me that was black that was doing
a joke about [ __ ] a white chick and
her saying the n-word or something like
that it wasn't ten minutes later this
guy's just like how come we can't say it
and the comedian had asperger's so he
was very like
who who what what are you saying
and the guy was like how come i can't
say
no and
everyone in the room was just like
what the [ __ ]
and i was about to go on i was standing
there just like
the show's over and that ruined the show
he got kicked out obviously he
or twice and then his wife started
chanting biden
wait like ironically i guess
like bite in yeah he was like this is
biden's america we're not allowed to say
the n-word in public
liberals ruin this country liberals
you're not allowed to scream the n-word
in the middle of a show
i brought that i'd bring that up in
arizona next time you're there it'd be
like trump lost here right the whole
crowd would be like no he did it
freaked out
you guys got gotta let him go dude let
it go
so did the comic explain why why they
couldn't say it
no he couldn't he was he was autistic
and he from love on the spectrum it was
michael it was not sam would have got
right into it
[Laughter]
no it was michael was like well we're
not allowed to say
that's not good who's the comic
i forget his name oh he was a local he
was a local guy yeah got you oh man did
you mention it when you came back yeah i
had 10 minutes on it what'd you say you
have to just like michael richards just
went there
brother started the show bring it back
in
bring that patriot back in don't take
him out
he's gonna love my set no what did you
say would you i forget i just they i
remember thinking about like that was
like a ride-or-die lady
the lady that like her husband yelled
the n-word and she's like
yeah
like she's sitting there with him like
[ __ ] like you guys want joe biden
when she said biden after you got kicked
out chanted it while while they're
getting kicked out because they're both
getting kicked out i wonder if you left
them her there that'd be weird but it
probably wasn't shocking to her that he
said that word definitely not but yeah
that's a couple that's gonna make it yo
say what you will about them you're not
getting divorced
[Applause]